are we talking about dating or  commitment here well so tell me about  that's a big difference tell me both  yeah so someone you'd want to take  seriously long term and someone you'd go  for a short term  someone long term no  um I can't I can't start a family of a  50 year old  um  no there's some some 50 Heroes out there  but not for me it's not doesn't work for  me but isn't the aim of dating like like  long-term relationships or is it just  like kind of fun depends on your accent  I'm not I'm not I don't I don't  personally date for fun I do I do  commitments  um so if I'm looking to get married to  someone then I'm going to be thinking  about my family and who I can build  something with